Johnny Depp's got a new love interest
and it's his lawyer but not the one you
think as you probably know by now my
name is Camille Vasquez yeah we're not
talking about Camille Vasquez the
breakout star of the actor's defamation
trial against his ex-wife Amber Heard
she shut down speculation they were
dating back in June and at the time A
source told E.T those rumors were
unequivocally untrue it's been
overwhelming so who is Johnny dating an
attorney from another case
Joelle Rich who represented the actor in
a libel suit in the UK two years ago the
one involving the publisher of British
tabloid the son Johnny and Joelle spent
four months together in court but
ultimately lost the case the case goes
back to a 2018 article where the Sun
newspaper labeled Johnny Depp a wife
beater for repeatedly assaulting his
then wife Amber Heard so Depp sued the
Tabloid for libel but a London high
court judge ruled that the newspaper's
claims were substantially true now it's
unclear when the relationship turned
romantic but we do know the london-based
lawyer is currently legally married and
is in the process of getting divorced
from her estranged husband
back in the little room again
while Joelle wasn't part of Johnny's
team in this year's headline making
defamation trial she was on hand to show
her support popping up at the Virginia
courthouse at least twice in May photogs
snapped her outside with Johnny and
weeks later she was seen hugging Camille
inside the courtroom since then the pair
hasn't been photographed publicly as
Johnny's kept a relatively low profile
getting back to work he's heading back
to the big screen as king Louis XV in
the new period drama John Dewberry plus
he's stepping behind the camera to
direct Modi a biopic about Italian
artist Modigliani I've gained some
degree of success in this industry I
mean I'm really it's it's been it's been
very it's been very good to me and it's
been very good for me a source recently
told ET Johnny's looking forward to
reclaiming his career quote he feels
like things are on the upswing for him
and like he cleared his name he's
looking forward to the future both
personally and professionally and feels
like he got his career back
[Music]